Well, the last question today regarding
Prophet Muhammad wasallam's statement
which you mentioned in your last answer
regarding the fact the uh the gates of
uh paradise are open and the gates of
hell are closed. Does this mean that we
will be going to paradise if we die in
this blessed month? This again is the
same question of the same hadith. Same
hadith which I quoted earlier of Musnad
Ahmed verse number two page number 230
had number 7148 and it also appears in
sunai chapter number five had number
21106. Again the same hadith the prophet
said he told the people that the blessed
month of Ramadan is approaching and
Allah has ordained for you that you fast
in this month and in this month the
gates of heaven will be open and the
gates of hell will be closed and the
devils will be chained in this month is
the night of which is more blessed than
a thousand months and a person who
deprived of the pleasures of the
blessings in this month is truly a
deprived person. Here again this is a
common question that if the gates of
heaven open and the gates of hell are
closed then anyone who dies but
naturally go to Jenna because the gates
of hell closed and Jenna open does it
mean that even if a non-Muslim dies in
this month even he'll have to go to
Jenna. The reply to this question is
when Allah says that in this month of
Ramadan the gates of heaven are open it
means the gates of heaven are inviting
you to enter Jenna.
That means that even if you do a small
deed, Allah subhanana wa ta'ala will
multiply your reward. And as a prophet
said that every deed will get a reward
10 times.
And in this month, it's very easy to
enter Jenna. When a prophet said the
gates of hell will be closed, indicating
that to enter hell is difficult in this
month. Why? Because the tawa level
rises.
And the chances of you to commit sin is
less. And furthermore, if you fast the
full month in the month of Ramadan
seeking Allah's reward, all your past
sins will be forgiven. So the moment a
person fast in this complete month of
Ramadan seeking Allah's reward, all his
past sins are completely forgiven. So if
the past sins are forgiven, the chances
of him going to hell is nil.
But what we have to realize the criteria
for the gates of heaven to be open and
the gates of hell to be closed is that
you have to fast.
And furthermore,
to enter Jenna, you require a ticket.
The ticket to go to Jenna is mentioned
in the Quran in surah als chapter number
103 verse number 1 to3 where Allah says,
that by the token of time man is verily
in a state of loss except those who have
faith. Those who righteous deeds, those
who exalt people to truth and those who
exhort people to patience and
perseverance. This surah according to
Imam Shafi he said that only if this
surah was to be revealed of the Quran it
would have been sufficient for the
salvation of mankind. So important is it
is called as rahenijat the way for
salvation and the criteria for any human
being to enter Jenna is four first is
iman second is
righteous deeds third is exorting people
to truth and fourth is exorting people
to patience and perseverance. So here we
realize that the gates of heaven are
open but just because the gates open you
can't enter you require the ticket the
ticket is iman the ticket is righteous
deed exing people to truth exorting
people to patient pursuance and to get
this ticket is very easy in month of
Ramadan because the iman level rises in
the month of Ramadan furthermore your
righteous deed the reward is multiplied
it's easier can call people to truth
your patient level increases. So this
hadith means that you have to have the
criteria that inshallah you should go to
Jenna and you will not go to hell. But
that doesn't mean that 100% people who
die will go to Jenna. Surely those who
are non-believers they have got no iman.
So there's no question that they will
enter Jenna.
If a person has to enter Jenna, he
requires a ticket and the ticket to
Jenna is surah als. Furthermore, if you
read the hadith, it says that only if
you fast in the month of Ramadan,
that means and you follow all the rules
and regulations and I pertain from
things which are prohibited, then the
doors of heaven will be open and the
gates of hell will be closed.
Furthermore, it says in this month is a
night which is equivalent
to more than thousand months indicating
that even if you pray and worship to
Allah subhanana wa tala in this one
night it will equivalent to more than a
thousand months is about more than 80
years imagine so the chances for you to
get reward only in this one night is
more than a lifetime an average human
being lives for 60 years so one
is more than a thousand months is about
more than 80 years more than average
life of a human being the chances are
very easy to go to Jenna and the ending
part of the hadith says a person who's
deprived
of these blessings is truly a deprived
person indicating that everyone will not
go to Jenna everyone will not find the
doors of heaven open it says the ending
part very important that a person who's
deprived of the blessings in this month
is truly a deprived person that means
telling us Muslims that if you cannot
get the benefits of the month of Ramadan
and then if you cannot go to Jenna then
you are truly a deprived person that
even includes the non-Muslims having
they are truly the deprived